I WILL HAVE YOU KNOW
THAT MY SELF-CENTERED ASS
JUST SCORED WITH THE HOTTEST,
SEXIEST WOMAN
IN THE WHOLE WORLD!
- I DON'T
BELIEVE IT.
- AND, SHE ONLY WANTED
TO TALK ABOUT ME.
SHE DIDN'T WASTE MY TIME
TALKING ABOUT HER.
OH, YEAH, AND WE HAD THE WILDEST
SEX YOU COULD IMAGINE.
IT WASN'T UNTIL
IT WAS ALL OVER
THAT SHE FINALLY ASKED FOR
SOMETHING FOR HERSELF.
- WHAT WAS THAT?
- $500.
I'M ASSUMING
IT WAS FOR CAB FARE.
AND I'M ASSUMING THE CAB HAD TO
TAKE HER TO A DIFFERENT STATE.
I'M ASSUMING,
MEXICO.
- STEVE, I THINK
THAT WOMAN WAS A--
HOW SHOULD I
PUT THIS?
- THAT BITCH WAS A HO!
- DON'T TALK ABOUT
LADY TANQUERAY LIKE THAT!
BESIDES, IF SHE
WAS A PROSTITUTE,
WHY DIDN'T I
WEAR A CONDOM?
RIGHT?
- STEVE, HOW MANY TIMES
HAVE I WARNED YOU ABOUT
TAKING PART IN
HIGH-RISK BEHAVIORS?
- OH, MY GOD.
SOMEONE JUST LEFT THIS
LAYING HERE?
WELL, IT IS
COLD AND FLU SEASON.
IS THAT CORNED BEEF?
I'LL GIVE YOU THREE BUCKS
FOR A BITE OF THAT.
WHO WANTS TO BECOME
BLOOD BROTHERS?
ALL OF YOU?
OKAY!
- FRANKLY, IT'S A
STATISTICAL MIRACLE
THAT YOU HAVEN'T
GOTTEN SICK YET--
- SEE?
- UNTIL NOW.
- WHAT?
- STEVE, MEDICINE DOESN'T
HAVE WORDS TO DESCRIBE
HOW HORRIFIC
YOUR ILLNESS IS.
I'VE NEVER
SEEN IT BEFORE, BUT--
WELL, TRY TO IMAGINE IF
SYPHILIS DID IT WITH CANCER
AND GOT FULL-BLOWN AIDS.
- CAN-A-SYPHIL-AIDS?
- YES,
CAN-A-SYPHIL-AIDS.
THAT HAS A NICE
RING TO IT, STEVE.
THE GOOD NEWS IS, YOU'LL ONLY
BE SICK FOR TWO WEEKS.
- YES!